In 2015, Volkswagen covered up a scandal that
affected millions of cars and
cost the company $30 billion.
There’s never been a better time
to buy a Jetta TDI Clean Diesel.
It started when the German automaker began a clean diesel marketing push
which suggested their cars were
environmentally friendly.
See how clean that is? It’s not dirty
but you still have a dirty mind.
Turns out “clean” diesel was just a dirty lie.
The automaker claimed it used a system that
helped convert harmful nitrogen oxides,
a common type of air pollutant, into harmless
nitrogen and oxygen. (SCR system called AdBlue)
NOx are a family of gases that can cause
asthma, bronchitis, and contributes to smog.
The U.S. Environmental Protection
Agency required new diesel vehicles
to emit no more than 0.07 grams of NOx per mile.
Volkswagen claimed it emitted no more
than 0.04 grams of NOx per mile…so
it was quite a shock when three students
at West Virginia University tested
two Volkswagen diesel cars and found
their emissions were off the charts.
They polluted way over the limit on
all of the five routes they drove
in and around San Francisco, San Diego, and LA.
According to their study, the
NOx emissions for Vehicle A,
the Volkswagen Jetta, were 15 to 35
times higher than the EPA’s standards.
Those for Vehicle B, the Volkswagen
Passat, were 5 to 20 times higher.
The car models were kept anonymous in the
paper, but we now know their identities.
This chart is especially revealing. The
green line way at the bottom reflects the
EPA emissions standards. The two Volkswagens
went wayyyy over the allowed emissions.
Emissions for the third vehicle they tested, a
BMW X5, crept up only during the hilly drive.
The scientists thought to themselves: were they
screwing up the tests? No, they couldn’t
be. They had driven the cars numerous times.
They began to suspect something that they didn’t
dare say out loud: Volkswagen was cheating.
It takes a lot of guts to accuse
a multi-billion dollar company,
the second-largest automaker
in the world, of cheating.
But that’s exactly what Volkswagen was doing.
The non-profit International Council on Clean
Transportation, which commissioned the study by
West Virginia University, turned its findings
over to the Environmental Protection Agency.
The EPA later revealed Volkswagens were
emitting up to 40 times more
pollutants than allowed by law.
Not only did Volkswagen deceive regulators,
it deceived consumers who believed they were
purchasing environmentally friendly cars.
So, how did Volkswagen manage to mislead everyone?
It had installed software that could detect
whether the car was being driven on
the road or tested in a laboratory.
When it noticed it was being tested
in a lab, the software told the car
to “behave” by activating controls
to temporarily reduce emissions.
It knew it was being tested in a
lab when the car acted differently.
Anna Stefanopoulou, a Professor of Mechanical
Engineering at the University of Michigan,
explained to Wired “computer sensors monitored the
steering column. Under normal driving conditions,
the column oscillates as the driver negotiates
turns. But during emissions testing, the wheels
of the car move, but the steering wheel doesn't.
That seems to have been the signal for the “defeat
device” to turn the catalytic scrubber up to
full power, allowing the car to pass the test.”
A catalytic scrubber is a device
installed in the exhaust system
of a vehicle to reduce the emission of
harmful pollutants like nitrogen oxide.
Once the car was back on the road, the
deceptive software would switch off,
allowing it to again exceed the standards.
When the researchers at West Virginia University
drove the cars on the road, they emitted far
more pollutants than when they tested the
same vehicles in a California laboratory.
In the lab - emissions were below
EPA regulations, shown in green.
The scientists did not explicitly
accuse Volkswagen of deception,
but it was clear when you read
between the lines: “ ...Vehicles
A and B were operating as intended
and did not have any malfunctions.”
In other words, this was no mistake.
The cars were operating exactly as VW intended.
Okay, so when they publish their study
in 2014, Volkswagen is freaking out.
But executives choose not to come
clean or admit to any wrongdoing.
Even though the California Air Resources
Board (CARB), which oversees air pollution
control efforts in the state, grew
suspicious and did its own tests,
Volkswagen argued that the
regulator’s testing was flawed.
That the outside air pressure affected the
results. That the routes were inconsistent.
Nevertheless, Volkswagen said it would update
the engine software for diesel
cars starting with 2009 models.
You might think Volkswagen was trying to fix
the problem of excess emissions. But actually,
the recall enhanced the ability of the software
to detect when the car was being tested!
In other words, Volkswagen used the
recall so that it could cheat even better.
After the software update, the
cars did emit less than they had,
but they were still not within legal limits.
The California regulator
grew even more suspicious.
It noticed emissions of nitrogen
oxides rose after 23 minutes of
driving…which happened to be one minute
after the end of a standard test cycle!
Volkswagen was cornered and couldn’t
come up with any more excuses.
In September 2015, it finally admitted
to regulators that its diesel cars were
equipped with software to cheat emissions testing.
It was later revealed that Volkswagen had been
aware of the cheating for years
but had chosen to keep it secret.
The U.S. Securities and Exchange
Commission claimed top executives
knew about the fraud as early as 2007.
At the time, Volkswagen’s market
share in the U.S. was a mere 1%.
It was trying to do what it could to compete with
Toyota to become the world’s largest automaker.
Yet it knew its engines couldn’t meet
America’s stricter emissions standards.
There were also allegations of
cheating in emissions testing by
other car companies but none to the same extent.
Volkswagen admitted that the software was
installed on 11 million of its cars - most
of them in Europe, where diesel-powered
vehicles were popular at the time.
The company recalled all 11 million vehicles to
remove the deceptive software and also to retrofit
the cars to meet emissions regulations
- a time-consuming and costly endeavor.
But the biggest expense came when
Volkswagen had to pay about $30
billion in fines and settlements,
which is far more than it would
have cost to install adequate pollution
control equipment in the first place.
Several top executives at Volkswagen resigned,
including CEO Martin Winterkorn who
maintained he was unaware of any wrongdoing.
The company insisted that the illegal software
was just the work of a couple of rogue engineers.
In the month following “diesel gate,” Volkswagen's
worldwide sales fell 5%. (October 2015)
There was even speculation
that Volkswagen was finished.
Yet, Volkswagen was able to weather
the storm and has largely recovered.
In 2022, it was the second best-selling
automaker in the world behind Toyota.
The company regained consumer trust in part
by introducing electric and hybrid vehicles,
advancing its commitment to
sustainable transportation.
It is determined to sell
more EVs than Tesla by 2025.
But there’s a long road ahead as
automakers have lost billions.
This doesn't just affect you trying to buy a car;
the everyday investor is getting
whacked by the tremendous price fall.
Because the S&P 500 is the most popular
index used by the public to build their
personal wealth, and it includes A LOT of
exposure to automakers and their stock.
But there is an asset class that has outpaced
the S&P by more than 130% over the last 26 years.
I’m talking about contemporary art.
The art market used to be impossible
to access unless you were super rich.
With Masterworks, everyone can enter the
high-end art market without spending millions.
You can invest in multi-million dollar
artworks by Banksy, Basquiat, and Monet.
All of the offerings have
been qualified by the SEC
And every painting Masterworks has sold to
date has returned a profit to investors.
The results from these eleven
paintings speak for themselves.
652,000 people have signed up for Masterworks.
There’s a waitlist for new users,
but you can skip the waitlist by clicking
on my custom link in the description.